Pythagoras is one of the most mysterious
and fascinating figures of the ancient
world with many Legends and ideas
attributed to him in our previous
episode on this Greek thinker we
mentioned the Pythagorean idea of The
Music of the Spheres a central part of
the mathematical worldview associated
with this group that had serious
implications for cosmology ideas of
Harmony and perhaps most importantly
music theory today we're going to talk
about this incredibly interesting
philosophical Theory one that has been
adopted by different thinkers across
history and which in many ways many
aspects of which are still relevant and
true today
[Music]
in the history of Western philosophy
Pythagoras and the pythagoreans are seen
as a key moment he has sometimes been
referred to as the first philosopher a
statement that can certainly be
questioned and many other ancient
philosophers such as Plato traced their
lineage back to Pythagoras as an early
important proponent of a wisdom
tradition that included many other
figures like Hermes and even Moses but
as we saw in the last episode we aren't
even really sure if he existed as a
historical person and if he did we can't
say much with certainty about his life
or his supposed teachings due to the
fact that all our sources are from
hundreds of years after he lived
assuming he lived Scholars tend to agree
that he seems to have been a charismatic
Sage figure who gathered a group of
followers in the city of Croton around
the 5th Century BC and which led a
certain Pythagorean way of life
concerned with asceticism knowledge of
the immortal soul and certain rules of
ritual conduct including a vegetarian
diet but as the centuries went by
Pythagoras and his followers became
Associated not only with this particular
Pythagorean way of life but also with
certain philosophical ideas surrounding
numbers and Mathematics Pythagoras is
attributed with holding a world view
where everything is essentially made up
of numbers and geometry a universe made
up of perfect mathematical relationships
and sacred recurring patterns reality
was math and numbers in other words
problem is there's no real evidence that
Pythagoras at all taught or held these
kinds of ideas
with that said the later pythagoreans
probably held these ideas for a reason
and so it isn't completely Unthinkable
that some of these themes can be traced
back to the man himself and even the
earliest Pythagorean thinkers of whom we
have direct accounts or fragments such
as filo Laos and architas seem to have
put a major emphasis precisely on
mathematics and how the relationship
between numbers is a significant aspect
of the cosmos and whatever is the case
with Pythagoras himself we can be sure
that the pythagoreans as a school as
much as they can be called an actual
School were definitely characterized by
these kinds of ideas and we can see how
this thinking is incredibly influential
on later thinkers like Plato and
especially the later neoplatonists who
were very much concerned with Concepts
like the one as a core aspect of reality
now how much of this actually comes from
pythagoreanism or was rather projected
onto Pythagoras by people like Plato is
a discussion for another time
but among the most famous and
significant aspects of the Pythagorean
mathematical Universe was the idea often
called The Music of the Spheres
this is a theory that implements many
different fields mathematics and
geometry astronomy and music and
proposes a kind of unified vision of
reality
to the pythagoreans as we have said all
of the universe is governed by a
mathematical patterns and ratios
in many ways this is still considered
true today as we can find math basically
everywhere mathematics is a language we
use that seems to correspond to some of
the deepest truths about how reality
works and the things we observe in the
world often follow very predictable
patterns and rules just think of the
Fibonacci sequence and the golden ratio
for example which we can find in so many
aspects of nature in different ways all
following the same mathematical pattern
to the pythagoreans the universe is
harmonious perfectly so in fact
everything follows the perfect rules of
mathematics and its Harmony
and ideas of Harmony are of course
directly related to music which arguably
is concerned with Harmony in different
ways thus to these thinkers the universe
was musical because mathematics and
music are intimately connected being
ruled by the same ratios and structures
there is a famous story often told where
Pythagoras is walking along in the
marketplace and listens to these sounds
of hammers striking anvils he suddenly
has a realization that a hammer that is
precisely twice as big as another will
produce a sound that is harmonious or
beautiful when played alongside the
other
he had discovered the octave
this story obviously probably isn't true
but it does illustrate the key point a
discovery attributed to Pythagoras that
seems to prove that music is a direct
reflection of mathematical Harmony and
even though this probably wasn't
Pythagoras's Discovery it's actually
true the octave as well as other notes
in a scale follow a set of patterns of
intervals that are mathematically sound
any notes or any sound really is based
on a frequency and frequencies are
represented by the unit called Hertz and
say we have any given note like an a
note at 440 Hertz for example
if we double that number to get to 880
Hertz we have a perfect octave two notes
which sound really good together
furthermore if we add the original
frequency three times we get to 1320
Hertz which is what is known as a
perfect fifth another one of the most
common and Quantum pleasing intervals in
music without boring you too much with
music theory we can see that the
pythagoreans were totally right all the
music we listened to is at least to some
degree governed by these perfect
mathematical ratios and intervals that
make notes sound good or harmonious
together so the reason certain notes
sound good together to us like the tonic
and the perfect fifth which is like a
universal interval in all music is not
just because someone at some point said
this sounds good and then everyone just
followed it actually is based on on how
mathematics works and how nature works
there is something within the intervals
and ratios of these notes that are
mathematically sound and probably for
that reason they sound good together to
our ears it's really fascinating stuff
mathematical Harmony manifests as
musical Harmony app to the pythagoreans
we think notes sound good together
precisely because they reflect the
fundamental building blocks and patterns
of the universe itself this becomes even
more profound when we consider what is
known as the harmonic series when we
hear any note not just on like a guitar
but any sound in nature that note
includes the bass note or frequency
which is called the fundamental but also
a bunch of overtones that we don't
really hear right but they make that
sound what it is and these overtones
amazingly follow the exact same pattern
that we have just talked about the first
is always an octave followed by a
perfect fifth another octave a perfect
fourth a major third and so on it's
pretty mind-blowing actually that these
patterns are found in basically all the
sound the sound of a singing bird
follows the same mathematical rules as
thus you striking the string on a guitar
it seems like our old friend Pythagoras
was onto something right he was for sure
but it also gets a little more
complicated this is why I said that all
music in some sense follows these rules
because the pythagoreans also tried to
construct a 12 note octave scale based
on these perfect ratios in particular
based on the perfect fifth and it
doesn't really work notes eventually
start shifting around and acting
strangely resulting in a limited use for
the theory turns out things weren't as
perfect as Pythagoras hoped the scale we
use today in music known as equal
temperament is based on dividing the
perfect octave into 12 equally spaced
intervals which doesn't align exactly
with the perfect Pythagorean
mathematical ones although they are
still very close although dividing the
octave into equally spaced intervals is
kind of mathematically harmonious in its
own way but in a different way you could
say so when you hear most music today
basically all music today it doesn't
actually follow these Pythagorean
mathematical rules if it had used those
Pythagorean intervals and notes it would
actually sound wrong to us and there is
of course a lot to be said for the fact
that the reason we think certain notes
sound good together is also because of
cultural conditioning and that we are
used to certain things sounding this way
because we've grown up and we've
listened to music in this way all our
lives there is that aspect of it too
despite these nuances the basic features
of the Pythagorean idea is still true
musical Harmony is ruled by these very
precise math mathematical rules
especially core intervals like the
octave perfect fifth and perfect fourth
and it's no coincidence that these
intervals are probably the most
recurring in music Across the world
regardless of all the other particular
features like quarter tones and such
things the octave and perfect fifth and
also perfect fourth are basically
Universal probably because it just makes
sense on a mathematical and Cosmic level
which we thus respond to on a personal
level when we hear those notes together
speaking of the cosmic level this is
where we get to the actual spheres of
The Music of the Spheres the Ancients
believe that the cosmos was essentially
made up of concentric spheres the Earth
of course was at the center of the
universe and then there were a number of
spheres extending outwards each with a
planet that revolved around the center
in perfect circles at the furthest point
was the sphere of the fixed Stars
now because everything in the universe
is governed by a mathematical Harmony so
were of course the planets and spheres
since they also are very important and
foundational aspect of that universe
the movements of the planets in their
spheres follow the ratios and rules that
govern the rest of the cosmos as a
result of this the planetary spheres
made music
their movements and following of these
harmonic rules resulted in them emitting
their own sounds or in other words their
own music this wasn't audible music of
course we can't hear The Music of the
Spheres as Aristotle points out in his
very critical account of this Theory
instead it's a kind of higher form of
Music the audible version we can hear
only be a kind of relatively pale
reflection after all according to this
world view everything is music
since music and Mathematics are
essentially the same thing all of
reality is musical since it is
harmonious and ordered according to the
same rules and patterns when we hear
music in the form of sounds this is a
manifestation of the fundamental
principles of the cosmos itself
including the movements of the Spheres
and the music that they make it's a
powerful idea and one that influenced
many thinkers across history even until
today Plato himself and his arguably
most influential dialogue the Timaeus
describes the creation of the world
according to mathematical and musical
Harmony the demiurge meaning Craftsmen
in Greek creates the world perfectly
according to the precise proportions of
Music These spherical Universe with its
revolving planets all form a cosmic
Harmony that follows the intervals of a
musical scale in particular it follows
what is known as the Dorian mode which
Plato was particularly fond of so the
whole universe as fashioned by the
demiurge is an elaborate musical
composition in a way and our ideal way
of living as individuals and as a
society is to be in tune with this
musical Harmony which will result in
peace and well-being in fact the
performance and listening to actual
audible music thus becomes an important
aspect of this process on a human level
according to Plato
later still the 6th century Christian
philosopher boethius continued in the
same manner carrying the Pythagorean and
platonic ideas forward into the Middle
Ages
in a work called on the fundamentals of
Music the institution he presents a
similar musical cosmology where
everything is ruled by the principles of
arithmetic and its Harmony in fact in
the work he classifies music into three
categories
first is musica mundana this is The
Music of the Spheres or music of the
cosmos this is the highest form of Music
produced by the harmonious movements of
the Spheres and the cosmos in general
with its recurring mathematical or
musical patterns this is the kind of
music that cannot be heard by the ears
but only understood
then there is musica Humana this is
music on the human level in the sense of
a Harmony between the human body and
souls what kind of spiritual Harmony you
could say and lastly there is musica
instrumentalis and this is music as we
know it's like music that we can hear
and play using instruments or the voice
while these categories are listed as
different in this sense by boethius they
are of course unified in the fact that
they follow the same rules and ratios
it's only different aspects of this more
holistic complete Universal Music right
everything is music and music manifests
itself in different ways in one sense in
the in the Spheres and in the cosmos at
large which is this inaudible music also
in the soul and of course also in the
actual audible music that we play and
sing and listen to they are different
manifestations of the same phenomenon
namely the musical or harmonious nature
of the universe as a whole even as late
as the 17th century with figures like
the famous astronomer Johannes Kepler
who is very significant for our current
understanding of the solar system we
find similar ideas he is of course
perhaps most famous for suggesting that
the planets move in elliptical orbits
around the Sun but he was also
interested in other aspects of
philosophy in his harmonica's Mundi the
harmonics of the world Kepler attempts
to sketch a picture on the cosmos in
particular of astronomy that conform to
the geometry and rules of musical
Harmony
at this point the Pythagorean scale had
been abandoned in favor of a more
reliable one but the principle Remains
the Same
the planets and other features of the
natural world are akin to a kind of
musical composition different parts of
the world are like instruments in an
orchestra playing beautiful harmonies
together or more particularly in this
case like a choir of different voices
singing together
Kepler clearly takes influence from the
pythagoreans or at least as they were
transmitted through people like Plato
and boethius but he also makes some
significant Innovations and and and and
and brings new aspects to this whole
Theory Kepler wrote quote the Heavenly
motions are nothing but a continuous
song for several voices to be perceived
by the intellect not by the ear a music
which through discordant tensions
through syncopations and cadences as it
were progresses towards certain
pre-designed six voiced cadences and
thereby sets landmarks in the
immeasurable flow of time
end quote the different planets are
presented by Kepler as different voices
in a choir singing together and he even
relates certain planets to specific
musical notes it's a profound
philosophical work in many ways and in
general Kepler makes some important
Innovations to the general idea that he
adapts from thinkers like Plato
for one thing Kepler of course lived in
a time when the geocentric model of the
cosmos had been abandoned instead basing
his version of The Music of the Spheres
on a more correct heliocentric model
where the sun is at the center
furthermore Kepler also implements
polyphony into the system to extend the
harmonic possibilities something that
wasn't present in the ancient authors so
as you can see the basic ideas adopted
by the early pythagoreans have stuck
around for quite a long time it
influenced not only other ancient
figures like Plato but much later
figures in history too all the way to
people like Johannes Kepler in the 17th
century in the modern world even today
there are many people who look to this
Theory as an attractive way to look at
the world and one which seems to align
with modern mathematics the Contemporary
principles of string theory as a way to
explain the fundamental futures of the
universe often uses explicit musical
language too albeit in a very different
way from the theories of the
pythagoreans of course today we know
that our friend Pythagoras if he even
had these ideas was wrong about a lot of
them the view of the cosmos held by the
Ancients has been discarded today and we
know that our solar system and the rest
of the universe looks a lot different
from the planetary spheres imagined by
ancient thinkers so in this sense The
Music of the Spheres kind of falls apart
in that particular sense at the same
time though we saw that modern thinkers
like Kepler could still implement this
theory in this way of looking at the
world it is in spite of having a
heliocentric model rather than the
ancient way of looking at the world
through these spheres so it can be
adopted and implemented in various ways
even though we don't adopt the
particular cosmology of the Ancients
right likewise we know that when you try
to create a 12 note octave scale using
the perfect fifth things aren't as
perfect as Pythagoras hoped he would
probably have been pretty upset to know
that things like irrational numbers
indeed seem to be a thing and our modern
scale system forces us to break some of
the rules that pythagoreans would have
preferred but again in terms of the
basic Notions of these ideas they still
accurately explain the world and music
in many ways there is indeed a strong
connection and correspondence between
musical intervals and mathematical
ratios the music we hear be a piece by
Bach the latest song from Harry Styles
or the beautiful calling of a bird it
all follows the same mathematical rules
and patterns the universe may not be
perfectly harmonious at all times as far
as we can know through our mathematical
language but arguably it is most of the
time
everywhere around us are fundamental
mathematical patterns that make up the
very foundations of things like the
Golden Ratio or the perfectly
symmetrical rules of a triangle The
rhythms of people walking or the falling
of raindrops in this way it's all music
and the amazing thing is that actual
music in its foundations follow the
exact same patterns and relationships
the harmonic series of any note which
determines intervals like the octave and
perfect fifth remains constants that
remind us of the beauty and symmetry of
the world around us a musical Universe
where we all contribute to the Rhythm
and Melody of the grandest Symphony of
them all
I'll see you next time
[Music]